madame monsieur bonsoir il était 13
heures 30 sur la crête du lauzet dans
les hautes-alpes lorsqu'une avalanche a
emporté un groupe de 32 personnes
composées en majorité d'adolescents le
bilan évolue d'heure en heure pour
l'instant sept morts et quatre disparus
le premier ministre devrait se rendre
aux orres dans la soirée en compagnie de
ségolène royal et de marie george buffet
une avalanche parmi les plus meurtrières
de ces dernières années alors que depuis
plusieurs jours le risque maximum
d'avalanche avait été atteints autour de
la station des orres c'est l'imprudence
qui serait sans doute à l'origine du
drame
sur place à cros d'importants secours
près de 150 personnes sont à pied
d'oeuvre
ils vont travailler toute la nuit
reportage alban nicosie
très rapidement les secours sont arrivés
ici sur le site de l'avalanche
l'armée de terre la sécurité civile la
gendarmerie plusieurs centaines d'hommes
mobilisés pour rechercher tout
l'après-midi d'éventuels survivants
la coulée a eu lieu vers 13h30 ici au
dessus des premiers sapins le groupe
comprenait une trentaine de personnes il
effectué selon les premiers témoignages
une randonnée en raquettes lorsque
l'avalanche l'ensevelît déclenchée par
monsieur le préfet des hautes-alpes
immédiatement et ont été dépêchés sur
place
douze hélicoptères 12 équipes de maîtres
chiens et plus d'une trentaine de
secouristes pour retrouver les 32
personnes impliquées dans l'accident une
véritable noria d'hélicoptères au poste
médical avancé installé en contrebas de
la station des orres c'est ici que sont
dispensés les premiers soins selon la
gravité de leur état
les blessés sont ensuite acheminés vers
les hôpitaux de la région
gap pour les pathologies les plus
sérieux ce serait le cas d'au moins deux
jeunes le groupe est constitué d'un
adolescent de la région parisienne tous
choqués par l'accident
en effet ce groupe de vingt-six
adolescents sont tous élèves au collège
saint françois d'assise à montigny le
bretonneux en banlieue parisienne ses
élèves de 4e âgés de 13 à 15 ans étaient
en classe de neige
on imagine la tente et la douleur des
familles et des enseignants tirer curtet
françois granier les informations sont
arrivés par bribes ici au collège saint
françois d'assise
prévenus vers 15h45 de la catastrophe ce
fut ensuite une très très longue attente
car les premiers bilans n'étaient que
provisoires
ils sont passés progressivement de
quatre à sept morts et bien 18 heures
seulement une seule victime était
identifié c'est à ce moment là car hiver
les premiers parents d'élèves
quand on va quelque part quand on amène
les gens quelque part surtout des
enfants que la météo dit attention
risque d'avalanches
on n'y va pas sinon on est des brutes ce
normal on n'y rien on n'y a rien du tout
il ya encore cinq sous la neige moi je
suis tranquille pour moi pour ma fille
qu'elle col du fémur cassé vers
attendant et à la synchro derrière
quelques élèves sont venus au collège
pour avoir les dernières nouvelles de
leurs amis
le proviseur et l'équipe pédagogique ont
organisé un accueil pour les parents
leur transmettant les informations au
fur et à mesure qu'elles arrivaient mais
à cette heure ci encore ou provisions ne
peut que répondre partiellement à leur
attente nous rejoignant maintenant en
direct du collège j'ai tiré et kurt est
en compagnie du proviseur alors je sais
que c'est très difficile mais est-ce que
vous nous confirmer à peu près le bilan
qui nous parvient sept morts quatre
disparus
écoutez pour l'instant le bilan on le
sait ici n'est que bien évidemment
provisoire le proviseur est juste dans
la salle d'à côté j'espère qu'il va
pouvoir nous rejoindre d'ici une minute
ils continuent de répondre aux questions
des parents des parents particulièrement
touchée quand ils ont appris la nouvelle
quand ils sont arrivés ici
ils sont d'autant plus touchés qu'il
règne une grande incertitude quant au
nom des victimes et au nombre de
victimes et vers 19 heures lorsque
l'équipe pédagogique ici a compris qu'un
certain nombre de parents rencontrerait
de grandes difficultés
eh bien on a fait appel à des médecins
et les psychologues pour les réconforter
merci tueur et le groupe d'adolescents
partie le début de la semaine de la
région parisienne séjournait dans un
centre de vacances de l'ucp à l'union
nationale des centres sportifs de plein
air un organisme connu pour son sérieux
le groupe était encadré par huit adultes
dont un guide de haute montagne et je
vous propose d'écouter le directeur
général de l'ucp à paris au micro
d'olivier galzi je vous paie peut-être
en balade à raquettes sur le manteau
neigeux ils redescendaient dans la
vallée suite à une sortie réalisée sur
le gîte de la draille est situé aux
alentours de 15 cents mètres d'altitude
c'était la dernière sortie de la
dernière journée d'activités sportives
il devait rentrer effectivement sur la
région parisienne demain matin donc il
avait déjà emprunté ce chemin depuis
plusieurs jours je ne peux pas faut
venir s'il a déjà emprunté les chemins à
je ne connais pas personnellement ce
massif
mais à ma connaissance et les activités
programmées en prime pédagogiques et des
guides expérimentés donc tout à fait
classique et un numéro d'appel à été mis
à la disposition des familles ce numéro
est le 01 45 87 46 55
il fonctionnera bien évidemment toute la
nuit je vous propose maintenant
d'écouter le témoignage
du responsable d'un refuge de la station
des orres il avait déconseillé ce matin
au groupe de s'engager sur ce parcours
nous l'écoutons professionnels comme moi
ils connaissent le problème de la
montagne comme moi peut être moi même
comme si la pratique encore plus unis
sans accompagnateurs et guides
donc il ne fait pas à moi de leur dire
si oui ou non ils peuvent aller sur un
secteur comme celui là je ne m'explique
pas pourquoi si l'on perd sur cette voie
là il est obligé de passer aux tirs au
but est de montrer aux jeunes
derrière ça me paraissait tout à fait
concevable votre compte d'épargné ne
pose pas de problème par contre évitez
de sortir tout est là apparaît
effectivement dangereux et vous leur
avez bien hélas au bout du nez fait
affiché est affichée ces derniers jours
les risques d'avalanche on l'a dit tout
à l'heure était au maximum les chutes de
neige du début de la semaine accompagné
de vents sont à l'origine de s'écouler
les explications avec benoît gadret et
olivier jacque l'un des hautes-alpes la
haute-savoie d'importantes chutes de
neige ont été enregistrées en début de
semaine sur tout le massif alpin
cela n'a rien d'extraordinaire à cette
époque de l'année et pourtant le risque
d'avalanche était encore ce matin au
niveau 4 sur une échelle qui en compte
cinq tout simplement parce que ces
chutes de neige ont été accompagnés de
vents forts ce qui a provoqué la
formation de ce que les spécialistes
appellent des plaques à vent
ces plaques parfois épaisse n'adhère pas
la sous-couche elles sont compacts en
cas d'avalanche c'est l'ensemble de la
plaque sur toute sa surface qui dévale
la pente
le risque est d'autant plus élevé que la
plaque à vent est très difficile à
repérer c'est très difficile de deviner
la présence ou de la suspecter le
manteau neigeux tient tout seul mais
c'est vrai qu'à la moindre surcharge
selon sonné je peux partir sur les faits
par exemple un skieur d'un surfer
éventuellement du chutes de neige mais
tant que la plaque n'est pas parti c'est
vrai qu'il reste très très difficiles à
localiser et à suspecter ce qui explique
régulièrement des professionnels de la
montagne soit victime de ce type
d'avalanche la pratique du hors-piste
est donc fortement déconseillé pour les
jours qui viennent selon les
spécialistes le risque d'avalanches dans
les alpes reste très élevé et comme bien
souvent les drames de la montagne sont
provoqué par l'imprudence ou la
négligence des randonneurs ou des
skieurs arnaud boutet sur la paroi
enneigées de skieurs entament leur
descente sur un domaine hors piste est
soudain
les avalanches sont souvent meurtrière
car incontrôlable sur une neige fraîche
et vulnérables les spatules brise la
couche et provoque découler pour éviter
les accidents et sécuriser les pistes on
a souvent recours à l'explosif au petit
matin avant l'arrivée des skieurs les
flèches atteignent leur cible en
montagne il s'agit de déclencher en
amont le maximum d'avalanche contrôler
une parfaite connaissance du manteau
neigeux constitue la meilleure
prévention
plusieurs communes disposent de
commissions de sécurité parle de la
commission se défendre de d'aller voir
sur le terrain avant avant d'envoyer ce
choeur et de vérifier n'y a pas un
risque manifestement trop importants
quoi pour envoyer les dix que
remplissent lorsque le danger est trop
grand on ferme les pistes bien souvent
les skieurs disposent de toutes les
informations sur les risques d'avalanche
au départ des téléphériques les
inconditionnels du hors-piste les
connaissent voici le gadget qui peut
sauver une vie
un bip qui permet de repérer un corps
sous la neige
selon le conseil supérieur du sport de
montagne 43 % des décès surviennent hors
piste et les avalanches ne sont à
l'origine que d'une intervention sur
1000 l'hiver dernier
cinquante deux personnes ont trouvé la
mort au monteur sur place d'importants
secours je vous le disais tout à l'heure
près de 150 personnes sont à pied
d'oeuvre et vont travailler toute la
nuit
je vous propose de rejoindre tout de
suite notre équipe est arrivée sur les
lieux de la coulée olivier théron didier
beaumont et henri orioles c'est en
marchant à flanc de montagne sous cette
crête que les 32 personnes ont déclenché
la coulée de neige
les 27 enfants les quatre
accompagnateurs n'ont rien pu faire
ce sont des tonnes de neige qu'ils ont
enseveli très vite l'alerté a été donnée
par balise radio et un important
dispositif de secours s'est déployée sur
la crête des nausées cent cinquante
sauveteurs des crs des guides de haute
montagne et des moniteurs venue de la
station des orres à l'aide de perches
ont sondé la neige à la recherche des
victimes
sur place aussi une vingtaine de chiens
d'avalanche sont mis à contribution il
faut faire vite la durée de 10 sous la
neige n'excède pas 15 minutes
c'est que c'est une plaque à vent qui a
enseveli un groupe de personnes pour
l'instant on en a retrouvé une 6
initialement on pense qu'ils étaient 32
le renseignement est assez floue puisque
apparemment les gens qui encadrent et
malheureusement sont décédés maintenant
il nous en manque un peu depuis d'autres
corps ont été sortis de la coulée de
neige ils sont ensuite évacuées sur le
poste de secours avancé et sur l'hôpital
de gap
les raisons de cet accident sont connus
de tout ceux qui pratiquent la montagne
ils proviennent des plaques à vent
le manteau neigeux est rendu instable à
cause des conditions météo
c'est que le manteau neigeux en ce
moment est très peu stable parce qu'il
ya beaucoup de plaques à vent il ya eu
deux trois jours il ya eu beaucoup
beaucoup de vent on a eu un fort mistral
ici qui a provoqué de grosses plaques à
vent d'accord donc là dans l'autre ya
des endroits en ce moment bon savons une
chose c'est que si on n'est pas sur le
domaine des ormes il ya des endroits où
effectivement des avalanches sont partis
qu'on n'avait pas vu partir depuis une
dizaine d'années il resterait encore
trois corps dans la balance et les
sauveteurs s'apprête à les rechercher
toute la nuit au poste de secours avancé
à côté de la station des orres les
hélicoptères continuent leur noria c'est
le préfet des hautes-alpes qui coordonne
les secours
actuellement 27 personnes ont pu être
dégagés à l'heure où je vous parle il en
reste donc 5 ensevelies parmi ces 27
personnes un premier bilan est en cours
un certain nombre d'entre elles ne sont
que légèrement blessés
fortement traumatisées fortement choqué
évidemment un certain nombre d'autres
sont blessés plus brillé très plus
grièvement et même certaines très
grièvement
le procureur de la république est arrivé
sur les lieux en début de soirée l'
enquête sur les circonstances de cet
accident tragique est désormais ouverte
et nous retournant maintenant en région
parisienne rejoignent en direct thierry
cure terre en compagnie du proviseur
thierry pouvez vous nous confirmer le
bilan que nous venons de recevoir bien
écoutez je te suis posé la question à
monsieur le proviseur quels sont les
derniers chiffres qui sont en notre
possession il y avait trente deux élèves
qui étaient partis avec deux de leurs
professeurs
il semble à 7 minutes que nous ayons des
renseignements sur 27 d'entre eux pour
les autres nous ne savons pas vous ne
savez pas où vous ne voulez pas donner
ni chiffre ni bien évidemment les non
vous n'avez pas d'identité pour
l'instant absolument pas qu'elle était
qu'il était de 7 classes qu'est ce
qu'elle faisait dans ce dans cette
classe de neige alors c'était une classe
qui s'appelle la 4e et sport qui est un
projet d'années de travail de réflexion
sur le sport et qui comme tout les
quatrièmes sport chaque année laver
avait choisi une semaine de découverte
et cette année il avait choisi d'une un
travail à cames en talent donc ils sont
partis avec deux de leurs professeurs et
ils sont partis bien entendu dans un
centre où il ya des gens compétents et
spécialisée à savoir le cpa et ils sont
partis en début d'après-midi pour une
randonnée
ils sont partis accompagnés de
spécialistes parce que les spécialistes
leur avait dit qu'il pouvait partir
il semble que ce soit effectivement une
avalanche qui a été déclenchée par des
skieurs hors piste c'est l'information
qui m'a été donnée par le professeur que
j'ai eu au téléphone et par le major de
la gendarmerie qui m'a appelé dans
l'après-midi mais je n'ai pas de détails
supplémentaires
est ce que vous aviez obtenu l'accord de
l'académie point cette sortie bien
entendu nous avions déposé en temps
utile à l'académie les pièces
nécessaires pour obtenir l'accord pour
ce voyage
nous avions également fait la formation
qu'il fallait aux familles et nous
avions fait ce qu'il fallait au niveau
des assureurs bien entendu aussi du
provisoire
l'avalanche qui s'est produite en début
de journée parmi les plus meurtrières de
ces dernières années le rappel de ces
catastrophes
olivier galzi
la montagne tués nous le rappelle chaque
année septembre 96 massif de la
maurienne
c'est ici qu'elle avait frappé pour la
dernière fois quatre chasseurs alpins
avaient trouvé la mort emportés par une
plaque de glace de plus de 150 mètres
même les montagnards les plus aguerris
ne sont pas à l'abri 29 janvier 94 col
du palais cette fois ci personnes
trouveront la mort engloutie sous la
neige six skieurs hors-piste pourtant
guidé par un moniteur professionnel
novembre 92 cette fois il ne s'agit plus
de hors piste du jamais vu à val thorens
la neige déboule sur l'une des pistes
principales surpris sept skieurs seront
emportés et puis il ya bien sûr 70
l'année noire
deux avalanches à deux mois d'intervalle
pour le bilan le plus terrible que la
montagne française ait connu
113 morts depuis et en tout le mortel
manteau blanc aura donc recouvert en
france plus de 150 personnes et jacques
chirac a fait part de sa profonde
émotion le président de la république
que dans un communiqué fait part donc de
sa très grande tristesse après la mort
de ces adolescents et exprime sa
profonde compassion aux familles des
victimes
voilà donc ce que l'on pouvait dire ce
soir sur cette catastrophe et nous
rejoindre en fin de journal
nos équipes en direct venons en
maintenant au scandale qui secoue la
maison blanche et qui pourrait menacer
l'avenir politique de bill clinton le
président des états unis désormais
soupçonné de subornation de témoin se
dit prêt à s'expliquer en public dès que
possible la sphère dépasse largement le
cadre de ces escapades sexuelles puisque
enregistrements à l'appui
la presse affirme que bill clinton a
demandé à une ancienne stagiaire de nier
la liaison qu'est la rue avec lui
pendant un an et demi
maryse burgot bill clinton que l'on voit
ici à la maison blanche il y a trois ans
avec la désormais célèbre monica
levinsky bill clinton est aujourd'hui un
homme cerner au point qu'il va devoir
s'expliquer devant le public américain
dans les jours qui viennent
selon le porte-parole de la maison
blanche très tendue lors de son briefing
quotidien
une conférence de presse devrait être
organisé clinton cerné par les médias
qui se sont emparés du scandale la
couverture télévisuelle et sans
précédent aux états unis les enquêtes et
révélations des journalistes sont
accessibles sur internet
newsweek publie même le script d
enregistrement d compromettant de
conversation de leninsky clinton cerner
enfin par ses propres contradictions il
ya six ans il déclaré à la télévision
américaine n'avoir jamais eu de relation
avec jennifer flowers for samedi dernier
lors de sa confrontation avec paula
jones
il aurait finalement reproduit cette
liaison le scandale ne cesse donc de
s'étendre et paralyse littéralement le
travail de la maison blanche
madeleine albright secrétaire d'état
vient d'ailleurs exprimé son inquiétude
à ce sujet et comme le président al gore
elle a réitéré sa confiance au président
depuis maintenant trois jours les
télévisions américaines sont en direct
en permanence de la maison blanche
émission spéciale interruption des
programmes dès qu'un protagoniste de la
sphère s'expriment tous les
présentateurs vedettes qui est est à la
havane à cuba pour la couverture du paf
ont été rapatriés d'urgence pour contre
attaquer le président des états unis
évoquent l'existence d'un complot
politique monté par ses adversaires
républicains
un homme un super procureur avocat
proche du parti républicain crack bill
clinton depuis 1994 c'est kenneth starr
qui a enquêté sur toutes les affaires de
la famille clinton
eric monnet il s'appelle kenneth starr
et star
il est en train de le devenir lui qui
semble avoir juré la perte de bill
clinton depuis 1994 le procureur
indépendant star est en charge des
dossiers compromettants pour le couple
présidentiel de la faire whitewater un
imbroglio immobilier à la sphère
politique
cette femme qui accuse bill clinton
harcèlement sexuel jusqu'au ko monica
lewinsky et rien ne semble arrêter
kenneth starr ni les moyens déployés
énorme 30 millions de dollars déjà
dépensés pour ces enquêtes ni les
marchés passés avec les témoins n'at-il
pas promis comme la loi le lui permet
l'immunité à monica levinsky en échange
d'aveux complets sur ses relations avec
clinton un acharnement que la maison
blanche embarrassé explique par les
penchants républicain reconnu du
procureur star des républicains qui
n'hésite d'ailleurs pas à mettre leurs
meilleurs avocats et leurs finances au
service d'une politique jaune ce pourvu
qu'elle maintienne ses accusations quant
à linda tripes
l'ex employé de la maison blanche celle
qui a fourni au procureur les
enregistrements compromettants
elle ne cache pas non plus ses
préférences républicaine pour les amis
du président un complot politique en
somme rien de plus une position de plus
en plus difficile à tenir
s'il apparaît que bill clinton a menti
une fois pourquoi pas deux trois ou dans
chacune des affaires instruite par le
procureur
voilà le calcul de canesta le piège se
refermerait alors sur le président comme
un autre piège s'était refermé en son
temps sur richard nixon le poussant à la
démission
sur ce plateau edouard baer bonsoir
honecker à newsweek l'hebdomadaire qui
sort les enregistrements de monica
lewinsky qui a été piégé par le fbi pour
vous est ce que la défense du président
qui s'appuie sur un complot pelletier
qu'est ce que cette défense tient encore
complot dans le sens classique du terme
non parce que la jeune femme qui est
impliqué dans cette affaire est beaucoup
trop fragile pour être un espèce d'agent
provocateur mais à acharnement de
monsieur schio qui est convaincu que
depuis quatre ans la maison blanche et
en particulier le couple clinton lui
ment et fait tout pour une espèce
d'obstructionnisme délibéré oui l'or
reste quand même que richard nixon était
tombé lui aussi pour avoir menti et il a
été chassé par les démocrates donc on
peut imaginer un esprit de revanche
aujourd'hui
quoique le l'histoire nixon road again
c'est vraiment très lointain je vois
plutôt l'espèce d'acharnement d'un homme
le procureur indépendant en question qui
est furieux d'avoir été bernés jusqu'à
présent et qui se dit si je ne vais pas
sur cette affaire-là waï walter je
l'aurais dans une autre affaire qui est
une affaire sexuelle
alors justement au delà du vaudeville
sexuelle est ce que cela pourrait coûter
la place du président ça pourrait bien
sûr mais c'est il faut se rappeler que
nixon n'a pas été destitué par le
congrès et le sénat
il a démissionné parce que la menace de
la destitution existait or je crois que
malgré le fait que les républicains sont
en majorité au congrès et au sénat
il y aura une certaine hésitation avant
de faire tomber le président lyndon pour
une affaire qui relève quand même la vie
privée en deux mots à quel calendrier
judiciaire politique peut-on imaginer y
aura-t-il des étapes cruciales
il y a deux alternatives la première est
que les explications de clinton seront
tels que éventuellement la tempête
s'apaisera et sinon si par exemple la
preuve peut être faite que clinton a
menti sous serment
à ce moment là il faut voir si du côté
républicain il y aura vraiment une
volonté de procéder à la destitution
merci edouard baer a cuba le pape jean
paul ii a pour la première fois depuis
son arrivée condamné l'embargo imposé
par les états unis cette condamnation
faisait partie d'un message adressé à
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
fidèles lors de la célébration de la
messe dans une ville située à 500 km à
l'est de la havane et puis hier soir
fidel castro avait reçu jean paul ii au
palais de la révolution envoyé spécial
alan seulement
on a rarement vu fidel castro aussi
attentionné prévenant même et dans
jean-paul ii à marcher d'une main
secourable dans le dos il faut dire que
le palais du conseil d'état de la vanne
est un véritable labyrinthe d'ascenseurs
et de couloirs interminables
le pape ne marche pas vie et castro
parle parle parle encore comme à son
habitude
enfin il y abat sur les fautes graves
pour saisir ce moment historique est
posée fidèles n'aime pas beaucoup il ne
sait pas vraiment comment se tenir
il faudrait qu'ils nous payent pour cela
ils nous exploitent vous ne trouvez pas
un père oui oui c'est dommage acquiesce
jean paul fut fin de récréation les deux
hommes restent seuls et rien ne filtrera
de ce tête à tête
salsa au programme ce matin en revanche
akamai way villes de province dans le
centre-ouest choisi pour la rencontre
avec les jeunes cubains
jean paul 2 apprécie toujours ses rangs
bon mais la salsa apparemment le laisse
plutôt de marbre
il est vrai que le pape n'est pas venu
ici pour la musique mais pour délivrer
un message exhortant les jeunes cubains
à rester au pays à ne pas s'exiler et
condamnant une fois de plus l'embargo
américain
rien en somme pour déplaire à fidel
castro auquel le pape a tout de même
parlé aussi des droits de l'homme lui
transmettant une liste de prisonniers de
prisonniers de droit commun et de
prisonniers de conscience avec une
demande de clémence demandes reçues dit
on avec bienveillance par le lider
maximo
c'est bien le moins en algérie deux
nouveaux attentats l'un blida l'autre a
été évitée de justesse dans un bus de la
capitale
au moins quatre personnes dont deux
poseurs de bombes ont été tués la
politique française avec à la veille du
week end le petit déjeuner ce matin
entre lionel jospin et robert hue les
deux hommes ont tout fait pour affirmer
la cohésion et l'habitante dans la
majorité plurielle
après les fausses notes sur l'europe et
le mouvement des chômeurs et ce au
moment où le parti socialiste se met en
ordre de bataille pour les régionales
françoise david tout barnier lionel
jospin après
son invité robert hue arrivera dans
quelques minutes les deux hommes ont des
choses à se dire depuis quelques temps
le parti communiste fait un peu trop
entendre sa différence juge le chef du
gouvernement
il est peut-être temps de siffler la fin
de la partie tant que la majorité rose
rouge verte retrouve son unité
une heure et quart plus tard robert hue
sort rassérénés ça a été vraiment un bon
moyen ensemble de voir comment nous
allions contribuer chacun dans sa
fonction à ce que la majorité plurielle
continue d'avancer réussissent c'est mon
objectif et je les réaffirmer à lyon
j'espère donc pas de courte échelle à la
droite même si le gouvernement donne
trop peu aux chômeurs dit robert hue
dans france soir ce matin quitter le
gouvernement
c'est une hypothèse que je n'envisage
pas affirmer thing hier la majorité
plurielle a voulu montrer son unité
les partis de gauche feront liste
commune aux élections régionales pour la
première fois aucune photo de toute la
famille n'a immortaliser l'événement
mais promis juré au delà des déceptions
des uns et des autres et le mouvement
des chômeurs l'exemple la fidélité le
gouvernement est de mise
heureusement suspens et en
insatisfaction qui concerne l'action
conjoncturelle du gouvernement
souvient du produit parlementaire peu
denses en actions à long terme et le
long terme c'est dès mardi à l'assemblée
nationale l'examen du projet de loi sur
les 35 heures communistes et écologistes
ont été un peu entendus par le
gouvernement la majorité tout entière
devrait se retrouver pour voter ce texte
en belgique dans la sphère du trou l'un
des témoins connu jusqu'à présent sous
le nom de code x1 est sorti de
l'anonymat la jeune fille a été
interrogé hier par le nouveau juge
d'instruction
sa déposition concerne la jeune
christine vanesse dont le corps avait
été retrouvé en 1984 un témoignage
sujette à caution et une nouvelle fois
la police est mise en cause
à lourdes dominique maes la belgique ne
la connaissaient que sous le nom de code
x1
depuis un an régina louf avait fait des
confidences à la police hier la jeune
fille a décidé de parler au grand jour
devant les caméras de télévision
elle raconte son calvaire ses parents
qu'il amène un réseau de pédophilie et
surtout comment elles assistent malgré
elle au meurtre de cette jeune fille
christine van nuys c'était en 84 dans ce
bâtiment désaffecté
quand ils ont tué gris steam
plusieurs personnes étaient là il y
avait marc dutroux et michel nihoul du
tout j'en suis sûr sinon je ne le dirai
pas marc dutroux mais shen yun
pédophiles depuis incarcéré pour lé
meurtre de julie et mélissa un
témoignage a priori accablant et
pourtant aujourd'hui toute la belgique
s'interroge quel crédit accorder à la
jeune fille contradictions réponse
semble-t-il dictée par les enquêteurs la
police qui a recueilli son témoignage
est une nouvelle fois mis en cause la
relecture de ces procès verbaux
d'audition montre aujourd'hui que
plusieurs questions adressées à x1 était
orienté peut donc suspecté une
manipulation du témoin on peut également
suspecté dans le chef des personnes qui
l'ont interrogée la volonté de lui faire
dire des choses qu'elle n'avait pas
envie de dire où dont elle avait
peut-être tout simplement même pas
connaissance
depuis l'arrestation du pédophile marc
dutroux police et justice sont
régulièrement mises en cause
la classe politique n'est pas non plus
épargnée et certains évoquent même ici
un vaste complot un complot destiné à
protéger les responsables de réseau
pédophile
d'autres évoquent tout simplement une
véritable crise des institutions
une crise qui sera longue et dont il
sera difficile de sortir
inauguration ce matin des stations de
métro et de rer desservant le stade de
france par lequel devrait transiter le
28 janvier prochain
plus des deux tiers des spectateurs du
match inaugural france espagne la grande
fête du football pourrait être perturbée
par le préavis de grève du syndicat cgt
de la ratp qui jouent sur des arcs
travail aux heures du match mathieu chez
philippe visseyrias 30 embauches une
prime de 1300 francs spécial coupe du
monde
syndicats et direction de la ratp ont
trouvé un accord pour la ligne 13 les
80000 spectateurs attendus pour le match
inaugural france espagne peuvent
respirer
la ligne 13 et le rer b fonctionneront
mercredi prochain ainsi mieux de détente
mais la cgt maintient son préavis
sur les autres lignes du métro et du rer
le climat s'est détendu sur la n13 mais
pas ailleurs
d'ailleurs pas ce que je peux vous
assurer pour le métro et le rer que les
agents qui sont décidés à la faire la
grève s'ils ne gagnent pas ceci dit nous
ne sommes pas les 28 à 4h30 du matin une
prise de service les premiers métro
la cgt appelle ses agents à une grève de
trois heures en fin de service
c'est-à-dire entre 16h et 21h puis entre
22h et 1h du matin juste au moment où
les supporters arriveront et partiront
du stade devant cette menace qui touche
aussi certains dépôts de bus le ministre
des transports qui inaugurait des
nouvelles stations à proximité en appel
au sens civique
je pense que les choses peuvent se
régler et qu'au bout du compte le 28
il est important que tout le monde
participe à la réussite
qu'ils veulent j'ai confiance dans le
champ de la responsabilité
la cfdt accusent la cgt de confondre
actions syndicales et chantage pour les
amateurs le mouvement de défense de la
bicyclette propose un itinéraire
histoire de s'échauffer angoulême pour
le 25e festival de la bande dessinée
remise aujourd'hui du trophée très
attendue par les dessinateurs à savoir
le prix du meilleur album c'est léon la
came de nicolas de crécy qui en est le
lauréat dans les allées du festival
marie aline bruno pascal couillaud 728
festival margera est infidèle
d'angoulême démarrage sur les chapeaux
de roue avec sa bande lucéens rickli et
les autres le quinzième album de la
série des lucien rien de sortir pour la
première fois les garçons quittent leurs
banlieues
direction la californie les fans
attendent pour la dédicace margera n'est
pas là pour le grand prix il l'a eu en
il accompagne lucien son héros lucien
tapé anti héros justement et je crois
qu'ils peuvent s'identifier à lui tient
parce que lucien c'est pas le mec qui
gagne toujours qu'il arrive des choses
formidables
il arrive des choses comme
il peut arriver à tout le monde
les anti héros sont en pleine forme le
meilleur album 98 celle est pauvre et
malade
une nouvelle aventure de léo la cab
l'histoire d'amy nabeul intégral prêt à
tout pour réussir il faut absolument
stupide ils se laissent piéger par part
puisque le monde moderne ne peut nous
proposer de
depuis j'en ai mal dit bon d'accord
c'est plus facile de dessiner que de
parler pour un auteur de bd tient
margera un droit lui aussi à sa délicate
une production incroyable ce que fait
des albums de 150 pages 320 pages pour
le dernier mois il faudrait trois vies
pour une production en hausse pour la
bande dessinée en général la meilleure
vente de livres toutes catégories
confondues pour 97 est une bande
dessinée
plus de 700 nouveaux titres sont parus
l'an dernier dont 15 albums vendus à
plus de cent mille exemplaires à
angoulême il y en a pour tous les goûts
pour tous les âges
une attente 170 mille visiteurs d'ici
dimanche inauguration hier à saint
germain des prés de la nouvelle boutique
de giorgio armani le célèbre couturier
italien après des années travaux
s'offrent une immense vitrine à la place
de l'ancien drugstore nicole venu
langlois luc bachofen la transformation
usage de nos cités sans être le
caractère dominant de la seconde moitié
du ciel le quartier latin lui même a
changé de personnalités les plus solides
bastions n'ont pas résisté aux assauts
d'une évolution un placard
les nouveaux établissements ne se
veulent plus intellectuel mais
fonctionnait 33 ans plus tard la
boutique armani remplace le drugstore en
suscitant les mêmes polémiques les mêmes
réticences les mêmes résistances de la
part des germanopratin germain
soucieux de préserver leur village de
l'emprise du luxe ils se sont unis en
association en comité de défense ils ont
fait modifier les plans puis se sont
fait une raison et une grande angoisse
parce que c'était mon mac donald's
warman il faut pas l'oublier
donc on a quand même préféré armani
ensuite on s'est demandé si c'était
mille mètres carrés de vêtements s'il ya
autre chose quand on a appris qu'on
aurait un bar en restaurant un coin
librairie disque et un coin journaux on
s'est dit bon c'est le moindre mal
car joe armani étant déterminés à
s'installer à saint germain des prés et
pas ailleurs en souvenir de sa jeunesse
il a affronté les tracasseries
administratives les contraintes
architecturales qui ont retardé la
réalisation de son projet moi j'aime
beaucoup la guerre j'aime beaucoup la
lutte toujours fait ça dans ma vie
n'aimerais pas de voir des endroits
atypiques de saint germain qui vont
disparaître et à la place de avoir des
boutiques une boutique de boutiques et
de sillage regard l'église qui entrent
dans le magasin suis ravi tellement
ravie d'être là que au lieu d'organiser
une manifestation mondaine pour le
lancement de sa boutique armani a offert
un million de francs pour restaurer les
vitraux de cette aiguille la mode
représente aussi une création de beauté
de joie de vivre mais vous sentez bien
que tout est une affaire de proportion
mais par exemple
ces librairies qui entoure l'église ces
différents magasins ou l'invention se
donne libre jeu faut absolument que cela
subsiste si on veut que ce quartier
bref ceci unique de légèreté de votre
e
notre but c'est d'essayer de rapprocher
les anciens
quand on fait un peu l'histoire passée
de ce quartier avec des nouveaux
arrivants et menace se profile à
l'horizon
christian dior et d'autres vont arriver
les boutiques ferment trop tôt ce que
regrettent les nostalgiques c'est la vie
nocturne mais surtout une insouciance et
un esprit qui disparaît
à singer du sport avec une médaille d'or
pour la française mélanie suchet qui a
remporté le premier super-g de cortina
en italie en une minute 15 secondes 25
centièmes elle précède l'allemande
village à l'italienne cardiff vers la
sortie française et est un des grands
espoirs du ski championne du monde de
lui fin à 17 ans le jeune prodige a
ensuite disparu des compétitions à cause
de deux opérations au genou et à la
cheville et nous l'écoutons maintenant
tout de suite après sa victoire il y
avait deux trois endroits clés dans le
super g et puis tout le monde sortait et
on a eu beaucoup d'infos avec les
entraîneurs avec mes copines de l'équipe
ils ont beaucoup fait passer le message
comme quoi il fallait très bien se
placer à certains endroits pour pas trop
sortir
et puis finalement je suis arrivé à le
faire et puis à kitzbuehel en autriche
les français ont remporté la 2e et 3e
place dans la descente en deux manches
contre andy de la course avec alexandre
kara
la sprev dans le monde du ski c'est un
nom fait de rêves et d'angoissé la piste
de kitzbühel en autriche
une descente mythique peut être la plus
difficile du circuit
une piste qui fait ou défait les rois de
la descente
luc alphand il connu la consécration
d'autres s'y cassent les dents
aujourd'hui ni qu'est-il andrea motte le
norvégien ni roland à singer le tricheur
ou n'ont pu vaincre la streif la minutes
qui précèdent le départ bon lâche me met
vraiment dedans mais les dix minutes les
deux minutes avant noël si la rigueur on
peut annuler et repartir à la maison
contre mais heureusement nicolas burtin
n'est pas rentré à la maison
bertin déjà second à wengen la semaine
passée berthe récidive s'empare de la
deuxième place derrière le suisse didier
cuche
sous le regard ému de papa
nouveau podium également pour jean luc
crétier faîtier troisième de la descente
le ski français se réveillent un réveil
ou plutôt une résurrection pour adrien
duvillard du village grièvement blessé
l'an dernier à wengen
duvillard prendre le podium mais surtout
on retrouve le sourire
tu vas faire car acquise bulle 6 essieux
owen janvier à charles pasi vers le ski
hors cac religieux et mais au début de
saison je croyais pas et puis là ça
reste quatre français dans les quatre
premiers d'une descente ça faisait un
bail
ça n'était plus arrivé depuis 1970 à
deux semaines des jeux de nagano
on se prend à rêver
du tennis avec encore des français en
pleine ascension cédric pioline a
franchi le cap du troisième tour en
éliminant aux internationaux d'australie
l'espagnol alex corretja en trois sets 6
2 6 1 et 6 4
je vous propose maintenant de faire un
dernier point sur l'avalanche meurtrière
qui a emporté un groupe de 32 personnes
dont 26 adolescents début d'après-midi
dans les hautes-alpes albors nicosie il
fait désormais nuit noire sur le massif
du lowe's et dans les hautes-alpes mais
bien évidemment les recherches
continuent à la lumière des lampes de
survie cent cinquante secouristes sont
encore à pied d'oeuvre après toute une
après-midi de recherche
la coulée que l'on voit ici au dessus
des sapins s'est produite vers 13h30 sur
la commune de croo dans les hautes-alpes
très rapidement les secours sont à pied
d'oeuvre et notamment les brigades des
pelotons de gendarmerie de haute
montagne accompagnés d'une vingtaine de
chiens d'avalanche à la recherche des
disparus ensevelis un groupe de
personnes pour l'instant on en a
retrouvé une 6 initialement on pense
qu'ils étaient 32 le renseignement est
assez floue puisque apparemment les gens
qui a encadré
malheureusement sont décédés à quelques
kilomètres de là une véritable noria
d'hélicoptères au poste médical avancé
installé en contrebas de la station des
orres c'est ici que sont dispensés les
premiers soins selon la gravité de leur
état les blessés sont ensuite acheminés
vers les hôpitaux de la région
le groupe est constitué d'une trentaine
d'adolescents originaires de la région
parisienne tous visiblement choqué par
l'accident
et puis un numéro d'appel à été mis à
disposition des familles ce numéro qui
s'inscrit sur votre écran et le 01 45 87
46 55
il fonctionnera bien évidemment toute la
nuit je propose maintenant de retrouver
en direct à gap près de la station de
ski wallu le drame
jacques cardoze quel est le dernier
bilan que l'on peut faire à l'heure
actuelle jacques bien écouter béatrice
un dernier bilan fait état de
huit morts et quatre personnes toujours
portées disparues donc probablement
ensevelies à l'heure qu'il est toujours
sous la neige 32 personnes étaient
impliquées dans cet accident et les
blessés ont été transférés on vient de
le dire dans les vers les différents
hôpitaux de la région parmi lesquels
embrun briançon ou gap où nous nous
trouvons je suis aux côtés du directeur
adjoint du centre hospitalier de gap
donc quel état étaient les blessés
lorsqu'ils sont arrivés ici donc cinq
blessés ont été accueillis dans les
différents services du centre
hospitalier
le premier dans un état très
préoccupation est très préoccupant est
en cours de transfert vers le chr de
marseille les quatre autres présentaient
des fractures et souffrait d'hypothermie
est ce que certains ont pu faire un
récit des circonstances du drame n'ont
compte tenu de leur état de santé trop
choqués ils n'ont pas pu faire ce récit
vous même parce que vous avez dû mettre
en place des moyens spécifiques
oui donc dès 14h30 le centre hospitalier
a mobilisé ses personnels dans le cadre
d'un plan d'accueil massif d'accueil des
blessés et nous avons rapidement
constitué les moyens pour organiser un
poste médical avancé à aux orres à
proximité de l'accident
très bien merci et puis une dernière
information à l'instant même on nous on
nous signale que lionel jospin a atterri
à 20h30
a grenoble il va se rendre lui-même
personnellement sur les lieux de
l'accident
merci jacques cardoze voilà ce que l'on
pouvait dire ce soir sur cette
catastrophe nous y reviendrons bien sûr
dans toutes nos éditions
ainsi se termine ce journal dans un
instant la météo laurent romejko le
froid persiste puis le point route
valérie maurice 20h55 maigret et la
vente à la bougie avec bruno cremer
demain à 7 heures dans thé ou café
catherine ceylac reçoit carole amiel
j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver à
20 heures de ma excellente soirée merci
de votre attention
il
là